I would like to introduce Greg lap he is
from Y hat and he has flown here from
New York to give us a great talk on
ggplot so please give him your attention
uh let's get through this and we will
try and leave a little space for
questions at the end so go ahead ok I
can hear me okay good alright great so
I'm Greg here to talk about ggplot today
oh I'm up here so go over just what
ggplot is in case you're not familiar
with it I'll talk a little bit about
some other libraries how it compares to
things like matplotlib or d3 i'll
explain how it works the sort of the
best practices around using it walk you
through some use cases and then we'll go
into a tutorial in the ipython notebook
so I said I'm Greg I'm the CTO and
co-founder of Y hat Y hat is a startup
we're in New York and we help companies
manage and deploy their predictive
analytics and I won't plug it anymore
welcome back to gb point okay so what is
digi plot well ggplot was originally
implemented in our bi GaN a hat Hadley
wycombe familiar at all with our he's
built a lot of really great packages
that are extremely helpful in doing just
some of the routine and mundane stuff in
data analytics and ggplot is based on a
book called the grammar of graphics and
what it is is it's basically a
domain-specific language for producing
visualizations particularly for data
analysis so think of all the things that
you've done when you're building a plot
or you're analyzing some data you know
stuff like making scatter plots
histograms assigning colors to
particular variables customizing titles
labels all of these things you know
you're doing them you're writing a lot
of code for it typically it's sort of
code that you
use over and over and over again and so
instead of duplicating that effort what
ggplot does is it condenses all that
down into a its own library its own
package where you can take those that
functionality and abstract it and make
it a lot easier and quicker to work with
so a lot of questions you might ask is
like well what about matplotlib like
Matt plot lives been around for a while
and I agree like matplotlib is a great
library but I think it's a little bit
out of date there are some things that I
really like about math lot lib but some
of the things i don't like are just like
the syntax an api i find a little bit
cumbersome I requires a lot of looping
which is sometimes a little bit awkward
when they're making plots and in
addition it's tough to learn in
particular for when you're taking
someone who's coming from our or someone
who's coming from even something like
Excel and trying to learn scientific
Python it can be extremely difficult and
frustrating for them to learn matplotlib
and as a result a lot of them just go
back to our so we've got sort of the
parts about matplotlib that I'm not
crazy about but there's a lot of things
that Matt plot lib does really really
well so it's been around for a while
it's extremely mature there's some
really great project maintained errs and
they do a really good job in terms of
just testing and stability it's got
great integrations with the ipython
notebook I think everyone has seen some
of these great presentations where
everyone is using the notebook and
everyone's got you know met plot libs
and there's Boca and all these other
plotting libraries now and then in
addition like you've got extremely
customizable charts where you can place
like particular labels or annotations or
what have you on your graphics and all
that can be done through the API so
we've got the good we've got the bad
figure out a way to take those good
things and really use them and so
so just to give you a really quick
example of sort of the meeting the bad
parts of matplotlib with the great parts
of G plot so Greg Rita he's an analyst
at grubhub he's a really cool guy talk
to him a few times but on his blog his
escuela like says fast at all things and
faceting it allows you to break down
different variables or components of a
data set and really break out break them
out into individual kind of plots right
here and really get a good sense for
what your data set looks like without
having to actually inspect you know what
would this be like 30 individual plots
and so it's a great way it's a great
technique for data analysis will do it a
little bit later in the tutorial part
but to do this in ggplot it is two lines
of code it's really easy whereas to do
this in matplotlib you got it right a
bunch of loops there's like adding
labels removing labels there's a lot
going on oops so you've got man Paul lib
and there's also d3 and d3 is great I'm
sure you've all heard of it and seen it
it produces great high-quality
visualizations a lot of times they're
interactive and this is the kind of
stuff that you see on the new york times
that my mom will give me a call and be
like how would you see that chart about
like life expectancy and texas or
whatever and we think of ggplot jeje
people it's kind of at the other end of
the spectrum whereas you feel at d3
where you're going to be working maybe
like a whole week on building this one
really killer visualization that you're
going to send to all your friends is
going to get nuked on red it's going to
be on hacker news everyone's gonna be
talking about it ggplot you're going to
build a thousand plots and not share
them with anybody you're going to throw
them all away and maybe there's going to
be one that you take and you send it out
in an email and you send it out to the
marketing team and the market head of
marketing so goes looks like an
interesting trend but think of it as
like ggplot
disposable really quick to use but it's
still extremely valuable d3 is more like
your buildings painting that you're
really going to want to show off alright
so hopefully you're sold on using ggplot
tell you a little bit about how it works
so one of the you think about like I'm
telling you all these great features
we're going to get at a ggplot so there
has to be some sort of trade off and in
this case the trade-off is your data
format you really have to use pandas if
you want to get all the features out of
ggplot which i think for most people in
this room that is fine wait I you know
everyones using pandas as a great API
makes them really easy manage your data
so you have to use pandas there are ways
that you can use numpy arrays and lists
but honestly I wouldn't even bother with
it stick to penis and so what it looks
like is you create a ggplot pretty
simple object initializer here put your
data frame in this case I'm just using a
built-in one here and then you accompany
that with aesthetics and we preview yet
abbreviate that at aes and so aesthetics
are how your plot looks and it describes
a way for just basically giving ggplot
instructions for how to build and create
your plot you know defining the x axis
to find the y axis that sort of thing so
an example we've got a dataset that has
us meet production over time but you can
see we've got the x axis is the date and
that winds up going there and then the Y
is our B for the production of beef and
all that's getting extracted out by
ggplot making this great looking great
looking fly and so there's other things
that you can or other aesthetics that
you can also use you can have color
shape size there's really there's a lot
some of them are shared between the
different types of
plots others are more custom and we can
get into that a little bit more in the
notebook okay so G own stats and scales
these are the building blocks of your
plots or of your visualizations and what
I mean by that is you take something
like a scatterplot ggplot that's
represented as something called genome
point and so when you add a jump point
to your ggplot you're going to get
something that looks like this and again
there's a lot of different types of
genomes I'm not going to get into the
mall right now but just know that there
are very many again same sort of thing
but instead of your typical bar plot
histogram what have you there's another
notion called a stat stats are simple
statistics that are commonly performed
on your data set most common one that I
use is just stat smooth where you apply
a trend line to your data and there's a
few others that come in handy you can
actually define your own custom one just
using stat function and then lastly we
have scaling your data so you know it's
not just enough to create these plots
you also want to be able to customize
the look and feel add different colors
different types of maybe you want a log
scale maybe you want some other label or
some other color mapping for your data
scales allow you to do that all right so
we've got the GG plots we've got the
aesthetics we've got genomes and stats a
last concept that's key and really
brings everything together our layers
and so what layers are is you can think
of a when you first create that ggplot
object we say ggplot you know my data is
this this cars data set I'm going to
have an aesthetics of an x and y that's
sort of your base layer and all that is
is you're just defining a coordinate
grid it looks something like this
and from there you work up and gradually
add additional features or additional
functionality to your visualizations so
you might want to add some points to
that and then you might want to take
that and add a trend line and the great
part about ggplot or at least what I
really like about it is that that is
really expressed in the syntax so the
syntax your you're quite literally
adding these components together which
is exactly how it's playing out in your
code and so when you add all this
together you're going to plot it has
points it has a smooth curve overlaid
over those points and you can get from
there so why you know why is this all
great well you know one of the things
that I really like what I'm using ggplot
is that it makes some reasonable
assumptions for you so things like we
have this field it's it's got two
categorical variables project alpha
projects alpha you throw this into
matplotlib and assigned color to this
field is going to flip out give you this
nasty stack trace and really you're like
really all you want is to just have two
different colors and start ggplot same
sort of thing defining this this plot
adding in that colors field and it just
sort of Ben knows it identifies like hey
it's categorical variable it's not
explicitly a color like red or blue but
what it probably means is that we're
going to want two different colors for
this for each category another great
thing about ggplot is that you can get a
lot of features and be extremely
particular about what's going to happen
in your plot without having to write a
lot of code so for example in in this
little snippet here we're defining X
y parameter we're actually creating a
formula in the color field so that we're
going to cast the cylinder or cyl field
from a numeric type to a categorical
type and we're going to add a scatter
plot to it and it looks like this if we
were going to do the same thing in
matplotlib you're going to have a lot of
looping going on you're going to have to
manually define labels title you're
gonna have to invoke the scatter command
a few times and in general there's just
a lot more code that you need in order
to generate what I consider to be a
pretty simple graphic and the last thing
is I think it looks pretty good so I
mean don't credit me like Hadley Wickham
built all these styles i just kind of
copied it but i think they tend to look
pretty nice they're nice enough that you
can put them in publications and you
don't feel embarrassed if you're sending
it out to other members of your team and
it's also extremely easy to customize so
for example I really like the way that
Seaborn plots work I think there's a
talk on that either later or it already
happened I'm not sure but it's a great
library you should check it out and
anyways I saw and I really wanted to be
able to do that from within ggplot so it
took me about 30 minutes I copied a
bunch of the code from the Seaborn
project just sort of pasted it into a
single file and all of a sudden I could
make Seaborn plots from jeanie plot okay
so since this is technically a tutorial
I want to launch into the ipython
notebook for a little bit here
okay so if you want to follow along feel
free there's a github repository so my
personal github G lamp / ggplot tutorial
and you can also there's a blog push
through it up today on our Y hat blog
that has the envy of your links for all
of these notebooks and also a link to
the github repo okay so since this isn't
a talk about pandas I'm not going to go
over cleaning and formatting all the
data that we're going to use just know
that we're using a data set that comes
from Major League Baseball it's called
pitch f/x it's really cool it's all
great i really like baseball but i think
i think most people that i show it to
even that don't like sports think it's
cool it's all public it's updated very
very regularly it might be in like
real-time or close to real time i'm not
sure but it's kind of funny you can just
go on mlb.com and if you figure out the
link structure here it's basically just
a big apache or something or other bunch
of xml files and they contain
information on on pitches in major
league baseball games and it won't go
through this will skip to the part where
we got it all cleaned in a nice format
but check it out there's a couple really
good our packages and there's also a
ruby client for extracting the data and
they work they work really well
alright I'm going to zoom in that big
enough you guys sit alright alright so
getting star with ggplot pretty simple I
typically just import everything for in
the global namespace I've seen some
people using it where they'll do like
import GG plot as GG but we haven't
reached PI data status yet where you
have like the convention that everyone
seems to follow so for now I recommend
just doing from ggplot import everything
there's a few data sets that ship with
the package one it's my sort of personal
favorite so meet data set and it's just
meat production in the United States
over the past half century or so and
it's great for time series it's really
simple pretty much anyone is going to
see it and understand what's going on
and then there's also a couple that ship
with the our version of ggplot as well
one is just a dominance data set again
pretty simple some basic basic features
about some diamonds and it's great
because it has a nice mix of categorical
and numerical features makes it good for
doing demos making slide decks and then
a couple others you know feel free to
check them out okay so got GG bought
here a way that you're typically going
to be interacting with it is through
this ggplot class it is technically a
class although you will interact with it
much more like you would a Python
function typically don't do call like
dot methods from ggplot and it takes two
arguments one is like we mentioned a
data frame elder are some aesthetics you
can put them in either position
I typically do this although that's just
my personal preference and kind of like
I was talking about earlier you create a
gingy plot and if you were to try and
render that just as it is you're going
to wind up with oops you're going to
wind up with just a big blank grid so
aesthetics talked about it a little bit
in the presentation aesthetics allow you
to really define and coordinate what
your plots going to look like it's
essentially just a dictionary with a
couple special properties there's a list
of available aesthetics for each geo min
each step on the documentation but
typically you've got x and y you can use
shorthand and it will assume that the
first jogger man is X the second
argument is why I threw two arguments
colors you see that here and also
supports Patsy formulas so I don't know
how many of you are familiar with Patsy
but you can do things like basic
arithmetic and you can cast categorical
variables using factor all right so
let's actually start doing some plots
that's what you're probably here for all
right so we've got our base plot here
actually creating a scatter plot you're
going to literally quite take your base
ggplot object and add a geo more add a
scatter plot to it and I can see
something looks like this so
pretty simple you can make one let's go
back get a little bit more complicated
there we go okay yeah okay so now we're
going to get into that baseball data set
that I mentioned it's got some pretty
cool information here so I'm going to
limit it to just a few columns there's
like 50 columns and it's kind of
information overload if you don't know
what you're doing but does that some
cool stuff like you know basic
information about the game hitter
pitcher these two coordinates p x + pz
define where the pitch actually landed
in the strike zone and then they also
have like I guess I just have like an
army of data entry people categorizing
all of these pitches that are happening
getting the radar gun how fast they're
going all that good stuff sure okay so
use case here I want to walk through
this data set and I'm just going to show
you how i use ggplot2 explore data set
investigate a couple of questions that
you know might arise as a result and
show you how you can dig a little deeper
and leverage some of the more advanced
features of GG plots so really basic
first thing I want to see is like the
strike zone data sounds kind of
interesting I wonder you know what it
actually looks like and so you can see
you've got this giant blob of data and
this is one of those instances where you
know just because you have a data set
that has like 200,000 observations that
doesn't mean you need to plot every
single one of them if you wind up with
this giant mess of points it's not super
helpful so what we're going to do is try
and investigate some relationships on
subsets of that data again
and looking at just speeds of the data
you can see that it sort of does this
mess of points so how are what are some
ways that you can take this data set and
actually you know use it and get some
helpful information out of it so one is
is histograms I make history REMS all
the time they're extremely extremely
useful great way to get a high level
view of you know what's going on with a
particular variable for this one I'm
going to look at the speed of the pitch
it's called starts p it's when it's like
the radar gun reading when the pitcher
releases the ball and so you can see
you've got data is distributed from
roughly like seventy to a hundred miles
an hour maybe one or two above 100 and
most of them are right around here
somewhere in between like 92 93 miles an
hour and so that you know that makes
sense to me and I checked out you know
just sort of looking to corroborate that
it looks at source of all wisdom yahoo
answers and you can see that you got
other people agreeing so and it seems to
make sense but what if we want is to
break that down and say all right so
what about four different pitches that a
pitcher might throw what are the speed
distributions looking like and so a bad
way to do that would be to loop through
a panda's group by and you get the
desired effect of finding that you get
all these histograms for each one of
your pitches but it's really hard to
read and a much better way to do that is
to use something called facet read so
facet wrap it's really helpful it allows
you to define that same histogram that
you used and two functions ago and you
can add this one line facet wrap pitch
name and what that's going to do is it's
going to take a name the pitch name
variable and it's going to segment out a
separate histogram for each of those
and so you can see here oops there we go
you can see here that we wind up with
all these different distributions and
there's one kind of interesting one over
here somehow there's the Efus pitch made
it in here I didn't know that people
were still throwing this but again stuff
is like tends to make sense right you've
got like fast balls go a lot faster than
changeup curveballs go a little bit
slower and sliders and so on and I won't
show it here but there's a video I'm
sure it's kind of funny this is like the
original Efus from the 70s it's kind of
funny kind of embarrassing I would
baseball players sir i I couldn't help
myself okay so what else forget so if
you want to investigate categorical
variables there's a way to make more
plots just called GM bar I've got this
variable called pitch type that is
whether someone whether a pitch with
wound up being a strike ball or was a
hit and so you can see here that we've
got X representing ball was hit s that
it was a strike and B it was a ball you
got roughly more strikes than balls and
then you've got you know roughly if you
summed the pitches that were hit with
the balls and be roughly equivalent to
strikes and it seems to make and be
pretty reasonable so similar to fasting
rap is facet grid facet grid allows you
to segment variables but instead of just
creating different plots for each one of
those variables and just string them
together in a big list it's going to
actually create a grid layout of both of
those it's the name so you can see here
that you can look at balls strikes and
hits on the same x and y axes it's just
kind of interesting because this going
you a good sense for whatever things
doing and it's all going to be lined up
other cool part about fast and courage
that you can go multi-directional so you
can have to two variables going at the
same time so here we've got ball strikes
and hits and then in this Y parameter
here we're looking at the different
types of pitches and so it just gives
you a little bit more insight into it
seems like strikes that are change ups
are like ok they're like roughly and
they're like 85 ish range the scales are
a little wonky here but you kind of get
the sex for what you can do it so
similar to histograms give a density
plot or a GM density GM density is great
when you want to compare variables and
some sort of sub segments of a
particular variable where the counts are
a lot a lot different give me an example
so young its speed here got kind of this
distribution of pitch speed similar to
that histogram we saw up top but then we
can look and sorry you can execute this
almost the same same piece of code
except we'll set the color of each one
of these lines to the name of the pitch
and then all of a sudden we've got all
of these different distributions and you
can see that ok like fastballs tend to
have the highest sort of mediator middle
value here you got the Efus down here
like 65 miles an hour and then you can
also see that where's our slider color
slider pink there's slider you know
somewhere in the middle so good way to
get a very like sort of high-level view
of your dancer
alright so that's sort of the basics of
ggplot some other features that i really
like are the intention on a little bit
earlier but the statistics or the stat
smooth and the stat identity those are
something that I always found extremely
difficult to do in either whether it was
like base are that I was using or in
that plot lib and it's a great way to
get us like a really do like a really
quick and dirty analysis on data so
again reading in my data here and we're
going to pose a question so how does
pitcher fatigue impact their velocity
the little pandas lunging here and all
I'm doin is subsetting out each game by
date and then doing a cumulative sum on
that field for each picture for each
game and what you wind up with is you've
like numbered what number or how many
pitches a pitcher has thrown in each
game alright so what we can do one thing
is we can create a big old scatter plot
and you wind up with this giant mess of
points so that's not super useful so you
know that we can't just look at all
these points individually there's just
too many of them so how can we aggregate
or how can we come up with a way to
actually make sense of this well my
favorite way is to use stat smooth so
what's that smooth does is it allows you
to take couple variables in this cage in
this case I'm going to plot the pitch
count on the x-axis and the velocity of
the pitch on the y-axis and it'll
actually compute a local localized
regression
on all of those points that we just saw
and so you can see in this you know just
as a baseball fan this makes sense to me
on average you've got the velocity
decreasing as a pitcher throws more
pitches and you can look out to like 120
pitches a game someone's and your
velocity is like three miles an hour
slower there's a lot of different ways
that you can use stat smooth one is you
can just adjust the span that's
essentially how many points are being
taken into consideration for the
regression higher is going to mean more
points lower means fewer points so I'll
drop it 2.3 here and you can see you get
a little bit more of the noise you're in
your chart there's also a few different
types of smoothers that you can use one
is that you can use a linear method oh
it's going here use a linear method
there's a basic moving average and then
there's the localized regression that i
already showed you all right so how can
we sort of dive in a little bit deeper
well instead of just looking at all the
pitches aggregated together because
obviously a fastball is going to go a
lot faster than a changeup how can we
break that out well if we subset by
color on and assign that to the type of
the pitch that was thrown you can start
to see and breakout trends on each one
of those and so sort of the same same
general idea you've got fastball getting
progressively slower it sort of tapers
off after 100 pitches its kind of
interesting knuckleballs go a little bit
faster but into the game which is sort
of flipping everything on its head but
it makes sense since the knuckleball
they're trying to limit the spin on the
ball they actually want to throw it as
slow as possible
okay so we've got all these like sort of
bigger more holistic news of the data
but you know what happens when we
actually break it down and start to look
at individual players so I just took a
look at oops there we go took a look and
found which pitchers were appearing the
most in this data set David Price came
up first and he's pretty good so I
thought it would be an interesting guy
to take a look at I'm not here so we can
look at him personally how does his
performance vary by any so you can see
that in general it looks like in the
first inning he's throwing a little bit
harder than he's throwing in the later
innings of the game if you break that
down by the type of pitch again you get
to see fastballs our peer hang up close
to 95 miles an hour you've got
curveballs down here closer to 80 and
then there's kind of like that general
downward sloping trend again facet wrap
is your friend you can use this to break
everything out individually and then you
can also apply same sort of statistics
and get them on it for an individual
player and so very quickly you can see
it it like okay there seems to be like
this clear kind of downward trend from
every prices fastball
I'll skip down here ok and then same
sort of plot segmenting out by pitch
count this time you can see that you can
you've got all these trends one thing
that's interesting they haven't touched
on yet is that if you put aesthetics
inside of the ggplot object here that is
going to be like a sort of like a
general parameter for your plot whereas
if you include them directly in the stat
or directly in the GM that's kind of
like hard coding a particular aesthetic
so you can see that like my size I'm
setting 28 and that's just like saying
look I want I don't want sighs to
actually be attributed to a particular
variable I just want these lines to be a
little bit bigger and then steam goes
for alpha one of these points to show up
a little bit lighter because I wanted I
really wanted to focus on the trend line
and then just kind of have the the
points be a backdrop for each one of
these so sticking parameters into the
functions down here still going to be
there but there should be hard code and
then if any of your baseball fans I
thought this was kind of cool I looked
at I did the same run on the data for
Justin Verlander and saw some pretty
interesting statistics and it's like Joe
Buck always talks about this in the
playoff is like how Justin Verlander
throws so hard throws harder as the game
goes on I never really believed him but
it looks like he actually does his
fastball is actually fastest the later
into the game that he goes kind of cool
okay so we've covered how you create a
basic ggplot how you add GM's and stats
to those plots lastly sort of i want to
cover how you can actually customize and
make your plots look a little bit better
so excuse me again loading in this
baseball data set i can look and see the
strike zone for every single pitch that
was thrown in this time point kind of
gets a little interesting you can see
that there's this big outer section of
balls with the orange in the middle
you've got that green which is all the
strikes and then in the very middle you
can start to kind of see a little bit of
a hint of purple and that purple are
those pitches that just went right down
the middle and got crushed I'm sure and
so you can look at that I segments ended
it out by shape just to kind of give you
a little demo of how you can do that
shape must be a discrete variable in
this case I'm using the name or the type
of the pitch that was thrown and so
there's a discrete number of excuse
there's just some street number of
shapes so again instead of looking at
the aggregate let's sort of drop down
and just inspect one particular hitter I
wanted to look at Mike Trout just
because he's really good and he appeared
the most times in the data set so I took
a look and I plotted every pitch that
was thrown to Mike Trout and where it
appeared in the strike zone so you can
kind of see they tend to concentrate
towards the middle again you see that
ring around of red red pitches that were
thrown as balls in the middle there you
got some strikes and then of course
there's some hits here and so we can use
that and we can actually color
ode we can customize the coloration
because I didn't really like the default
colors here so I know there was a demo
vid earlier in Boca tutorial but we also
have a like a scale color brewer which
will define separate palettes fruit
charts so you look it here the base one
is just gonna do blues but you can
customize it and say ok I have like a
qualitative variable I can assign type T
equal qual you can assign different
palettes so here I'll do you do too I
can bump it up to 34 here and I'll get
different set of colors so on ok so I
thought it would be cool you know not
just to have all these points here but
actually define the strike zone with a
bunch of lines so we can outline it and
see what's going on and where all these
pitches are actually landing relative to
where the batter is standing so we can
use GM each line and what that will do
is it'll create these lines right here
these horizontal ones I'm going to
define them and set them to this
variable strike zone bottom and strikes
on top so i can do that and then sort of
on the same the same pain i can define
vertical lines for the edges of the
strike zone and then lastly i'm going to
set the coordinates to be equal so that
one foot in the X direction and one foot
in the y direction they're going to be
equally represented in the plot and so
you can see here museum in a little bit
and see it seems like his sweet spot is
sort of in the lower left half of the
plate here and get a lot of called are a
lot of strikes around the top up here
again there's a lot of different ways
that you can adjust the color of your
data sets here I'm looking at the speed
of the pitch whenever is released versus
when it hits the catcher's glove and you
can see there's a generally like a
linear trend which makes sense pitches
fastest when it leaves this pitch that
either excuse me pitches fastest when it
leaves a pitcher's hand and slow us when
it hits the catcher's glove and I'm just
kind of color-coded all these points
just to kind of provide a visual cue for
the magnitude of the change from from
the pitcher's mound to home plate hmm
sorry
alright so another really handy sort of
gym that I use a lot is GM a beeline
it's just going to define a diagonal
line you can add different customize the
y intercept and the x intercept kind of
as you see fit so for example I can come
in here say want the y intercept me set
to maybe like 70 I me like 10 and rerun
things and that's going to just adjust
the whoops intercept and that will
adjust where the line is going to show
up that aren't droid takes a minute here
here we go ok so looking at another
picture will look at CJ Wilson just
another a little bit more interesting to
mix it up a little bit here but you can
see that we're looking at how fast he
throws pitches and where they show up
and then to define that and actually
make it a little more explicit I can use
the X lab why lab and GG title functions
these do pretty much what you expect
they do they define labels and titles
for your plot everything will default to
just showing up as vertical text or
horizontal there's one guy who's working
on making it so that you can have like
super customizable like diagonal like 45
degree angle text in like different
fonts but that'll be in the upcoming
release so again
scaling colors another thing that's kind
of cool to do that you can customize is
defining what colors you want to
represent on different gradients so
scale color gradient will take a
numerically assigned color field and
provide you with a sort of a color map
so instead of doing yellow and red wine
I'll do like from white to do like kind
of boring but ok you can see that you've
got counties gray guys down here and
then you got black ones up here all
right so what I really wanted to see was
for for this particular pitcher how can
we take the velocity that he throws all
across all those different pitches and
kind of compare it so that we can see
where he throws fastest in the strike
zone for different pitches so I wrote a
little function just to normalize the
pitch speed so that it was between zero
and one subset by the name of each pitch
and then from there and then from there
what we can do is we can actually plot
it and facet that and define the color
to be that normalized pitch speed so
that from within each one of these
little subplots here you can start to
see where he's throwing fastest where is
the slower and then if we want to break
that out even further we can just look
at yeah it's the same chart but without
faceted we can look at just sliders and
you can see that he tends throw hard
sliders kind of like down and in to a
right-handed hitter it seems to kind of
make sense for me but anyways a lot of
cool stuff you can do with color
gradient it's one
things that's way different than
anything that you can do in Excel and so
if you're looking for a quick way to
impress your colleagues I found it it's
really effective all right so kind of
last thing here is like customizing how
your plots look and feel it's really
easy the next release of ggplot is going
to it's going to be even easier right
now you have to actually implement your
own call a theme in the source but we'll
have it so that you'll just be able to
like on the fly define a custom theme
but I mentioned earlier seaborne it
makes make some really good looking
shirts so if I wanted to sort of
seaborne eyes that last short I just did
all I have to do is add a theme seabourn
function and all of a sudden I'm gonna
have a white grid line with gray gray
axes ticks and I really didn't have to
do anything else pretty easy and of
course everyone's favorite you can do
XKCD style charts it looks a little
ridiculous in this context but it's kind
of fun they look better I thought they
look better with like a lawn chair
accounting this yeah yeah
alright so I've got a couple minutes
here now I'll leave a few for questions
but just want to talk a little bit about
kind of what's next where the projects
going I'll be the first one to admit
that there's still plenty of bugs and GG
plots still really rough around the
edges it doesn't come close to the our
version but the are versions been in
development for three or four years now
and there's you know a lot of different
people working on the project but that
said you know I think the first release
of ggplot was in October and we've had
at least 30 separate committers which
has been awesome you know a lot of
support and it's becoming it's very
quickly becoming more and more mature
and the other thing I want to talk about
I think it's really cool but I don't I
haven't actually talked to anyone about
it yet but has anyone seen matplotlib d3
or and yeah it's really cool I have no
idea how it works but it converts
matplotlib figures in 2d three love JSON
charts
so one of the problems I run into with
my users is they want to look at their
data but there's always an outlier who's
the outlier and then they have to go
back and go through their code to try
and figure out who the outliers you just
hover on it yeah yeah I Jake van der
plazas got a great thing there's a lot
of people contributing to it it's going
to grow fast and from what I understand
I haven't read through the source but
I've read the spec and I played around
that a little you can write plugins for
it so hopefully you know everything will
either a you know best case it works out
of the box and and don't have to do a
lot of customization but you know worst
case maybe there's like a ggplot plugin
for MP ld3 but i can show you right here
I'm just using the really basic map are
not methyl and ipython notebook
integration with MP ld3 I can use it
make a little ggplot here and I didn't
run first and this is actually
JavaScript so if I come over here think
at the enable this guy here well it's
kind of cool you can actually like
interact with it and clearly I'm really
bad at if it works I guess it's a point
here
work in progress all right all right so
like I said earlier all the source codes
on github I'm going to post the slides
to SlideShare as soon as we're done here
and I just talked about what's next for
the project so we also I just released
some new docs who's long overdue and hey
look I think they look pretty good
gotten some good feedback on them
they're still again kinda like the whole
project still a little rough but the
goal is to make it super easy to find
help and well obviously super easy fun
help but provide a lot of examples for
how to use ggplot you can see that you
know it's going to be pretty simple
don't have examples yet but they're
coming so stay tuned for better
documentation alright so with that
thanks for coming out learn more about
ggplot and if anyone has any questions
I'm happy to answer them or try my best
this is really useful for people like us
at least I don't have to run many
different grammar of graphics one is in
our purpose going back and forth with
rm500 SMS I'm just curious in terms of
your coverage so I see you have pretty
much replicated exactly the
functionality of ggplot in our so what
are the corner cases where it's not kind
of working just out of curiosity and oh
sure so I go ahead and yeah so big
things and I was actually talking to
someone about this earlier the tough
part is the stuff that's native in base
are that you can't really see the
reference implementation or it's all in
like C++ are does things like the local
localized regression his native in our
and so in ggplot it's like Aaron Python
there's not really a great
implementation we actually had a couple
people Trey cause you was one he's a
great guy but I've had a couple people
help out because I'm not as good at the
statistics side of things so that's been
something that's been really great just
people helping out pitching in on some
of the harder stuff okay and the last
one is uh in terms of I guess the best
way to put it is I'm not able to frame
it right now so may I think about it
okay yeah right so I guess you just
answered it but um this doesn't call or
in any way just by throwing so
everything's everything's Python okay
because you use a lot of the datasets
like the diamonds and stuff I'm like
okay yeah it's a lot of it is from are
right but it's on my phone okay so um
this is mildly tangential but can you
look show me the stuff on factors that
you had up there has I've been looking
for where those live in the Python world
and I haven't found them into so they
live and I think they live in the util
file and
ggplot but I'm wondering if there is
what thing or a panda's thing or yeah
there it's a patsy thing so Patsy is
this really cool project that doesn't
always I don't think it gets enough love
it it's like an implementation of our
formulas and expressions in Python so
it'll allow you to do things like this
where you can define like a regression
formula and then you can actually use
that in library like stats models to
build a regression model so we use that
that same methodology for doing things
like factors and doing arithmetic from
within the aesthetics and from within
that string where you define what column
you want to plot ok I might have to talk
someone else but my what I was looking
for is basically these enumerations from
our is that the same kind of factor is
here Oh Mike categorical Mary yes uh
yeah I guess so ok so you can put these
in big tables and stuff I think yeah
okay I think if we understand your
question correct i'll have to figure it
out the answer is yes i have a question
for you so you use a lot of the plus
operator because ggplot does it whoa
loads plus operator I guess is that
isn't do that rather than method
chaining uh I think so I've we've talked
about I think there's an issue open
about doing a an object oriented layer
wearing where it's like you said it's
like chaining different things together
the problem with that is that sometimes
you wind up with like 10 different
things in the chain and that would be
look in Python you can you couldn't do
it like JavaScript where you can like do
a new line so that could be really ugly
but yeah I mean it's totally totally
possible I tend to like the idea of like
you're actually adding different layers
together and so it's sort of like a nice
a nice sort of like
visual cue as to what's happening
alright well thanks guys appreciate you
coming out you have any other questions
feel free to send me an email or
something so can we give him a warm
thank you for coming everything so we
basically have from 350 until 405 so you
can go take a break again if you're
going to be heading over to the other
location for the next set of tutorials
help us heard you guys into groups so we
can get you escorted over there if
you're staying that's great get up feel
free there's some fresh water and stuff
over here get something to eat and drink
and we'll get the next session set up
fairly soon thanks
you